This.
Is the Chris Abraham show.
This is the second try The Chris
Abraham Show season 10 episode
2.
First one didn't work out.
I ended up not having any focus.
I was not into it.
I was not feeling the vibes man.
We'll see if this one makes it
through.
If it does, Aloha.
Today I want to talk about the
I've written a bunch of sub
stacks about this with regards
to the FDR New Deal and I was
thinking that Donald Trump is
extremely obsessed with not
invading other countries.
And invading other countries is
the only reason America is so
successful, right?
The the best business plan ever
is to build expensive
consumables, and weapons are the
best expensive consumables in
the entire tea of the world for
two reasons. 1 you get to build
stuff, and then it explodes.
It explodes intentionally as in
bombs, or it explodes
unintentionally as in being
blown up.
It also it's really great for
development because you don't
have to go through any red tape
with regards to reclaiming land
that you can then redevelop,
right?
So I mean, it's just all good.
The only cost is lives, but that
seems to be acceptable for for
the hegemon.
So I was thinking since there
isn't the ability to.
Oh, by the way, the reason why I
know this is true is because ICE
is being so obstructed by
activists that Trump needs to
pivot to attacking other
countries because he needs to
keep the economy going.
But before he started doing
that, and he's going to do that
in a big way, the more people
defend illegal aliens from being
deported through their bodies
and their attacks and their
protests, the more Donald Trump
is going to invade Venezuela,
Nigeria, Syria, Sudan, etcetera.
So Chad, it's Yemen, it's going
to be awesome.
And so, I mean, Donald Trump is
really good at pivoting to make
sure the economy works.
He's going to do it at any cost.
There's two sides to the by any
means necessary, right.
The left is protecting against
Trump by any means necessary.
And Donald Trump won't be
obstructed like he was in his
first term by any means
necessary.
It's really fun to watch.
Anyway, my whole sub stack
series was about the deportation
industrial complex that I then
expanded into the deportation or
domestic War on Terror.
I'm going to call it the
domestic War on Terror versus
the global War on Terror.
And both things I believe are a
spending the trillion dollars of
defense budget, etcetera,
somewhere, right?
We can't invade Europe yet.
We can't invade Russia yet.
We can't invade Taiwan yet.
We can't invade China yet.
So in the meanwhile we need to
invade America, right?
So it's pretty easy to do.
A majority of Americans support
it.
They believe that 20 million
undocumented between they
believe that between 10 and 40
million undocumented people from
around the world, mostly
military age men have flooded
into their country because of
Biden's open border policy and
that there's probably hundreds
of cells, terror cells just
waiting to pop up and take
America hostage.
And so basically the deportation
industrial complex is a make
war.
Sorry.
That was what was it called A
that was a an intentional
mistake.
What is the term?
Hey Google, who's the most
famous psychoanalysis?
Sigmund Freud.
And I know it's psychoanalyst,
not psychoanalysis, but anyway,
it was a Freudian slip.
But yeah.
So the deportation industrial
complex is a, an FDR works style
make work New Deal, but in kind
of the what is the term in the
bizarro mirror?
You know what I mean?
Like the New Deal actually was
if, if you will, a
gentrification project.
I mean, I hate to say it, but
FDR was doing a nationwide
gentrification project.
I'm sorry if it feels heterodox
and insulting, but I actually
need to write about that.
That was.
Hey Google, what is the term for
when you take over land?
The government takes over land
in order to do a big project on
the.
Website justice.gov, they say.
Eminent eminent domain.
So in many ways, FD Rs New Deal
was a nationwide eminent domain
project in the guise of, in the
guise of of, of modernization
and liberalization.
I bet you if I dug deep, I bet
you if I dug deeper, it would
come across as extremely
authoritarian and despotic even.
And a lot of people accused him
of being that way in that the
works program was Hitler Lite.
It was this kind of American
pride thing with with with with
art and social realism and all
kinds of kind of it was it was
exactly the same time it was
post World War One, pre World
War 2.
So it kind of, I mean, if we
were to diagnose FD Rs New Deal,
we would say that it was it was
very Hitlerian just because it
had everybody's buy in.
I wonder if we'll ever get to
the point where we talk about
the people against which the New
Deal was weaponized.
Anyway, you can't touch the New
Deal.
The New Deal was is a sacred
time in America's history.
It is it is seen as effective
and active socialism, but it was
basically a make works program.
And my belief is that in a world
where you can't really, Donald
Trump is hesitant to invade
other countries, he needs to
engage the same number of
soldiers and and military men
and defenders of democracy, but
not Democrat democracy, but
defenders of democracy in terms
of imperialism and adventurism.
He needs to turn it inward.
So the deportation industrial
complexes is sort of an
extension of the private prison
system, right?
Hey Google, how much money does
the government spend on the
private prison system in
America?
$3.9 billion On the website
prisonpolicy.org they say total
U.S. government expenses on
public prisons and jail.
Total U.S. government expenses
on public prisons and jails 80.7
billion, plus on private prisons
and jails 3.9 So public prisons
and jails are $80.7 billion and
private prisons and jails are
3.9 billion.
So the deportation industrial
complex is just an extension of
that, right?
Where you can, if you need to
deport 40,000,020 million, 5
million, whatever people believe
the number to be, you need to
create an entire nationwide
infrastructure.
You need to build an infinite
number of detainment centers.
You need to hire an infinite
number of judges.
You have to hire an infinite
number of lawyers.
number of federal agents.
You have to hire infinite number
of FBI agents.
You have to hire an infinite
number of state police.
You have to buy an infinite
number of an infinite number of
sidearms and battle rifles.
You need to buy an infinite
number of black Suburbans.
You have to buy infinite number
of transfer vans and buses.
You need to charter an infinite
number of commercial airlines
and commercial jets or private
contract commercial airlines.
You need to feed and you need to
treat and you need to water and
hydrate.
You need to provide food and
lodging.
You need to provide medical
care.
You need to I mean, it's it's in
in, in, in Infinity system.
If you go to places like small
prison towns, the entire
environment, the entire town is
in some way associated with the
prison industrial complex.
So the deportation industrial
complex is a perfect situation.
And with this concept of Narco
terrace and this concept of, of
cartels and even the, the
definition of Antifa as a
terrorist organization is going
to expand it into what I said
earlier, which is D Watt instead
of G Watt, which is global War
on Terror, it'll become D Watt.
Which is this idea that an
infinite number of 9/11 type of
terrorists have inculcated and
infiltrated into American life
and are staging some sort of
terrorist event, multiple
terrorist event, government
takeover, American takeover.
And so that was why, while
people who wore red hats always
knew that Trump wanted to deport
all illegal aliens, he mostly
spoke about it as in getting the
big baddies, getting the
criminals, getting.
I mean, little did anybody know
that when MAGA people say
criminals, they mean anybody
who's in breach of their legal
residence, anybody who's
illegal, even if it's
administrative.
And here's the goal.
If you if you totally militarize
it and turn the people against
you, you can very quickly start
arresting people who are
protesting the deportation
missions.
So you can start, you can start
giving people misdemeanors and
felonies or at least disrupting
their lives completely, right?
Like this.
The entire thing is, is you
know, is planned.
I mean, it's all part of the
counter disruption, right?
It's taking, it's almost like
aikido or judo or Brazilian Jiu
Jitsu.
It's using the energy of
defiance and protest and going
ahead and, and, and destroying
the lives of those people using
their own of momentum.
So here we go to the works
program.
Like I said it, it requires
infinite resources to create an
environment where you deport 50
million people who are here
illegally.
And it is a, an amazing works
program because it's not just
ICE people, it's not just
detainment centers, It's, it's
it's detainment center guards,
it's security systems, it's
building, it's contracting, it's
security, it's it's HVAC, it's
catering, it's bedding, it's
shampoo and conditioner, it's
everything.
I mean, obviously if you want to
deport 50 million people,
there's got to be, you know,
500,000 detainment centers.
I don't know, it seems almost
almost incredible, right?
So, and of course the
intimidation, the trauma, the
fear mongering, the wearing
masks, the going in hot, the
dressing in JSOC drag, all of
that is intentional as well.
The, the system wants to
traumatize people who are here
illegally so thoroughly that
they consider America to be more
of a untenable environment than
actually where they're from, so
that they will self deport, even
if it's technically only
temporary.
So all of the, all of the
overreach, all of the, the flash
bang grenades, all of the door
kicking, all of the rappelling
from helicopters, all of that is
a, is a, a force multiplier.
And all of that is, is
intentionally traumatic
delivery.
It's delivery of trauma in such
a way that people cannot sleep
through the night and they're
like, screw it, I need to get
out of here.
And of course, secondarily the,
the sanctuary cities are kind of
like when the rules change, they
are like the best fishing
grounds in the entire world,
right?
Like that some it's like, it's
like the, it's like all the
criminals telling you where
they're going, right?
Like it's like back in the day
there in Hawaii, there are these
places called cities of refuge.
And there was these places of
refuge.
And of course, in the old days,
Catholic churches used to be
places of refuge.
However, in the new in the new
regime, those places, they were
only, they were only social
constructs.
Nothing was really legal about
any of them, right.
In terms of federal government
oversight of of, of mayors.
I mean, mayors don't governors
maybe, but mayors don't have any
when it comes to playing Jung
Jung Campeau, when it when it
comes to when it comes to the
force doctrine.
There's no way that a a mayor
can counteract a presidential
decree.
It it might look good for voting
and it might end up turning the
time of the American presidency
in in 2026 for midterms and
2028.
But really all Donald Trump
wants to do is to spend as much
of his military industrial
budget on internal make work
projects so that he can make
sure that everybody is going to
survive probably what is going
to be an economic downturn.
And so if he can create New Deal
style economies of people who
make, you know, primary,
secondary and tertiary money off
of giant deportation programs,
then there you go.
And then of course, there's the,
you know, domestic War on
Terror.
That is the next step, right?
Those people are not going to
deportation if you are.
That's The funny thing, right?
We talk about deportation as an
administrative thing, and that
is just as simple as grabbing,
detaining, deporting.
However, if you're literally a
member of a gang, if you're a
member of a terrorist
organization and if you're a
member of a cartel, you're not
going to be deported.
You're going to be put in
supermax.
And supermax is going to be in
wherever, wherever that foreign
prison is.
And there's foreign prisons all
over the world, right?
I guarantee you.
Like, I, I think one of like one
person was sent to Africa.
I don't know where in Africa,
but I assume that these supermax
prisons are kind of like boys
club or whatever.
Like there's it's totally NIMBY.
Like there's no place Americans
don't want supermax prisons in
their own country.
I mean, honestly, if you think
about it, these supermax prisons
that are in other countries are
similar to the penal colony
idea, right?
Out of sight, out of mind.
If you make sure your supermax
prisons aren't domestic, then
you don't have to.
Well, first of all.
You don't get to go ahead and
spend money in the country
supporting that supermax prison,
which is terrible for
employment.
But like, there's the balance,
right?
You nobody wants a nuclear
reactor in their in their
district and nobody wants a
supermax prison either.
So it's a real NIMBY thing.
America is a series of NIMBY.
I mean, California has become
the ultimate NIMBY state.
California has chased out it's
oil refineries.
It has chased out it's actually
California.
If you look at if you look at
Gavin Newsom and then you think
about the amazing story of oh,
Dorian Gray, the Picture of
Dorian Gray.
If you think about Dorian Gray
and you think about California,
you think about Gavin Newsom.
We can have a funny game here,
which is Gavin Newsom is
objectively a beautiful man.
Beautiful, beautiful, beautiful
man.
That head of hair I would die
for.
California is objectively a
beautiful woman.
Beautiful, beautiful, beautiful.
It's a beauty I would die for.
However, that beauty is at a
cost.
Every single pollution, poison
and political grenade that
California used to be known for
in terms of its industrial base
has been outsourced to China,
right?
So the Dorian Gray painting is
now in in not Beijing, wherever
the industrial work is actually
done in China, whoever makes the
stuff incurs the carbon
footprint and then removes all
sin from it, puts it on a
container and then sends it to
California where it can be
consumed without the carbon
footprint.
Right.
So, so it's, it's a NIMBY
project, but is it really NIMBY
if it's not only not in your
backyard, but not even on your
continent, Right.
That is really what modern
globalism is.
It's it's NIMBY writ large.
And NIMBY means not in my
backyard.
So, so, yeah, so, but the sad
thing is the secondary effect is
that California's driving
everybody out, right?
It's driving Anheuser Busch,
it's driving in and out Burger
HQ, it's driving out Oracle.
It it's driven out Tesla, it's
driven out the oil refineries,
it's driven out all kinds of
stuff.
So we'll see if, if and then
there's issues with water and
when it comes to things like
almonds and so forth, We'll see
if, if California will be a
sustainable project.
I hope it is.
I mean, really, it's a it's a
beautiful, beautiful place.
And if I won the lottery, I'd
probably move there.
And, and so, yeah, so we'll see
what happens.
It'll be really interesting to
see.
Oh, and this goes back to
another idea.
Forget about.
So domestic War on Terror it is.
So I wrote an article in
Substack,
chrisabraham.substack.com.
You can look there.
They're all like edited and
expanded with help of ChatGPT.
The images are ChatGPT prompts
and all the articles are like 30
minutes of me prompting,
prompting, prompting, prompting.
But the results are all written
for me by ChatGPT.
And then I re edit it, re edit
it, re edit it.
And then those really cool
podcasts are also super duper
lazy.
No notebook LM Google products.
So I mean, my ideas get across,
but it's not me sitting at my
typewriter, you know, for 35
hours to come up with a sub
stack.
I basically talk like this to
ChatGPT and it comes up with
something, which is what I'm
going to do here.
Like when I post this podcast,
I'm going to upload it to
Microsoft Word Online.
They have a transcript tool.
I will upload this MP3 to the
transcript tool.
It'll transcribe everything I
said.
I will share it to a document.
I will download it as PDF and
then I will upload it to
notebook LM and it'll just do a
bunch of stuff for me.
So they'll be charts, they'll be
infographics, they'll be after
this entire episode is done.
At the end, I'm going to append
probably an hour's worth of
notebook.
LM like tomfoolery in terms of
deep dives and stuff.
Hang around if you're
interested.
And so domestic War on Terror,
one of the things I wrote in
Substack was that every single
person we killed during the
Global War on Terror was, and
I'm not including, I'm not
including, OK, let me do a carve
out because the sentence was
supposed to be bombastic.
But I realized that when, when
George W Bush and his his
motley, his his motley fools
conned America into invading
Iraq, we did in fact fight
actual Iraqi soldiers.
However, in general, the entire
global War on Terror per SE was
against civilians.
And I, I, I shared this on to
Facebook and man, I got so many
responses because this idea of
the hegemon imperialist
superpower killing people who
are basically freedom fighters
who are taking up arms to defend
against invaders is just a
terrible narrative.
It really throws people off the
rail.
But basically that's what it is.
I mean, we were invading,
invading, invading.
We were radicalizing,
radicalizing, radicalizing.
We were calling freedom fighters
terrorists and killing them.
And people hate that.
But it's become a thing, right?
It's become a thing.
Global War on Terror says that
anybody that we call a terrorist
is a terrorist.
And as a result, you can drone
them.
So it's just a little step
between that and doing that
domestically.
So the domestic War on Terror
hasn't really taken off yet, but
all you need to do is turn
America into enough of an anti
progressive, anti antifa, anti
no kings, anti deportation
pressure cooker to make people
lose their stuff and start to
Red Dawn against the government.
Once they Red Dawn against their
own government and it escalates
into fisticuffs and small arms
and you know, the equivalent of
the 1970s with the Weather
Underground and climate
terrorism.
Like the pressure, the pressure
cooker can get to a point where
all you need to do is fool the
commies and the lefties and the
anarchists and the socialists
and the social justice warriors
and the climate activists and
the academics and the free free
Palestine people.
All you need to do is get them
to start firing and it'll
cascade into, you know, into
real world consequences.
There's that's the scary thing
about the right.
The right really subscribes to
the concept of don't fire until
you see the whites of their
eyes.
And so, so much trigger
discipline.
I'm always amazed when the when
the ICE, when the ice people
don't mow people down.
I'm always surprised and and
amazed when National Guard guys
don't mow people down.
I mean, I assume in a world with
anger, anger, anger and and
partisism, partisanship, I
assume that every day is exactly
like Kent State.
Every day ice is not like Kent
State.
I do a Hail Mary and I do it our
Father.
In fact, I should start doing 10
Hail Marys and 10 Our Fathers
every time.
A day does not end with the with
with the Kent State.
Considering the politics now, I
think every day should be a Kent
State.
I'm surprised I'm not going to
be worried about our government
until every day is a Kent State.
I like to tell people that I
don't worry about terrorism or
America's safety until America
feels like just like a normal
day in Tel Aviv or in Jerusalem.
Harkening back to when I was 16
and I was 15 or 16, I was
supposed to go do an entire
summer trip to Barcelona with my
high school as a an immersive
Spanish program.
And sometime in the mid 80s some
radical organization decided to
blow up discotheques and cafes.
I don't remember the details,
but until America becomes a
place, I'm not even impressed by
school shootings.
I mean that's just, that's just
cherry picking.
I do think nobody in America
cares at all about inner city
black on black gun violence.
I mean, that's, those are
literal numbers, but I mean the
things that affect people on a
daily basis.
Someone was saying on Facebook
that why do we care at all about
impoverished criminals on the
street when there are
billionaires?
It's not about the money.
It's not about, it's about
whether I feel safe, whether my
shit is safe, whether I can put
my car on, park my car on the
road and whether or not on the
street, I mean not on the road,
If I can park my car on the
street or in a parking lot and
it won't be broken into.
Nobody cares about the big
crimes.
People only care about the
crimes that personally affect
them.
If I go on holiday in two weeks,
am I going to come home to a
broken window and my TV gun?
Am I going to come out to my car
and my catalytic, my catalytic
converter is gone.
I wonder if, if, if, if a
Cadillac has a catalytic
converter and you know, whether
or not I'm going to be mugged
when I go out to dinner with my
with my partner or whether or
not I'm going to have start to
have the European problem of
pickpocketing.
Or whether I'm going to have
card when it, whether I'm going
to be carjacked at A at a four
way stop sign or whether when I
use the Starbucks bathroom and I
come out and if my laptop's
gone.
Like that's the only kind of
crime that people care about.
I don't even think they care
about, you know, assault or
anything else like that.
I mean, I'm talking about
domestic assault and sexual
violence.
I don't think anybody really, I
think people only care about
smash and grab if they're a
store owner, smash and grab or
looting if they are work in
retail.
I think that it really is just
like quality of life.
That's why people don't like
homeless people, though they
would never admit it.
They don't like marijuana use
because everything smells like
stinky weed, right?
Like, like people tolerate these
things because we're all
cowards.
But at some point, if you can
get away with something
drastically monstrous by dark of
night, that person's going to do
it.
I remember I'm 6 foot 3 and 300
something pounds.
So luckily I've never, oh, and
generally armed, but luckily
I've never been assaulted.
But like throughout the the
2000s, every single one of my
friends was, was what is it
called, was mugged by a, a 1312
or 13 year old kid at the end of
a, of a, of a cheap, like a
cheap revolver, a a Saturday
night special, right?
That's, but that was when you
are, when you are extremely
liberal, you just think that's
the cost of that's the cost of
life.
Like that's the that is in many
ways the the sacrifice to to the
sun God in order to keep in
order to keep everything going.
So, but you know, I mean, we
don't live in a proportional
society, right?
Like if you do that to someone
who's armed, they're going to
probably try to shoot you in
center mass, right?
So, I mean, it depends on where
you live and so forth.
But back to domestic War on
Terror.
That quite presumably might be a
thing, but I'm not going to be
impressed until every day is
like Kent State.
Until then, I'm super impressed
as to the trigger discipline of
these.
Like, for example, you know,
there are, whenever I think
about the relationship between
American law and order
enforcement and the people who
are like, all cops are bastards,
bootlicker, bootlicker,
bootlicker, fascist, fascist.
I think of the big yellow lab
who is endlessly willing to
suffer as all the babies of the
family pull its ears, pull its
tails, pull its, pull his tail,
jumps on top of it, you know,
and so forth.
It's only the the irony in in
America is the only reason
Antifa and BLM and protesters
and looters and so forth, the
only reason they can act out
mostly safely is because of the
benevolence and restraint of a
highly militarized and trained
superior force.
The ratio is not good.
Hey Google, what is the ratio of
Americans to law enforcement on
the.
Website UCR dot.
FBI In 2019, the average number
of full time law enforcement
officers in the nation's cities
was 2.3 per 1000 residents.
So there's only 2.3 all cops are
bastards for every thousand
residents.
So I mean if you were to start
shooting you could quickly be
overwhelmed by superior numbers
if not by superior superior
weapons.
I do not think you can call in
air support if you are domestic.
Domestic fascist brown shirt
Jack booted thug ICE officer.
I don't think you can get on to
your prick 77 and call in a call
in an F4 to do a strafing run or
a a napalm drop.
I don't think you can call in an
A10 Warthog yet domestically.
We'll see what happens.
And I also like to think in
terms of restraint and
benevolence.
There are 400 + 1,000,000 mostly
unused firearms in private hands
every day.
And that kind of goes to my the
people who own those guns have a
very strong trigger discipline
that says don't fire until you
see the whites of their eyes.
Hey Google, how many rounds of
ammunition are privately owned
in the United States?
On the website florida.com.
They sell.
Americans buy between 8 and 15
billion rounds of ammunition
annually.
There are 80 to 100 million gun
owners in the country.
So if you assume possession
based on sales alone, the
average American possesses
between 80 and 150 rounds each.
That makes sense, but when I was
going to the range, I would buy
thousand rounds of of reloads
off of the Internet routinely,
right?
Let's see, I have 1017 round
magazines and 315 round
magazines.
So that would be 170, yeah, 200
rounds.
I have 200 rounds of 9mm.
I have hundreds of rounds of 22.
But yeah, I think I have about
200 rounds of jacquard hollow
points in 1017 round magazines
and 315 round magazines and
that's it.
I do not have thousands of
rounds.
So I'm perfectly, I'm a perfect
exemplar of that anyway,
domestic War on Terror, there
probably are going to be loads
of false flag that false flags,
false flag events.
Really, honestly, nobody
actually does anything.
Nobody actually does anything.
And if there is any big event
like January 6?
It's always going to be fomented
by by a by a color revolution
agenda outfit.
It's either going to be fed or
intelligence or foreign or
regime based.
You know, at some point all
those people are be going to be
like, show me the whites of your
eyes already.
And and who knows?
I mean, like I said, I'm pretty
tolerant.
If if if like there aren't
multiple discos and cafes blown
up in the United States on a
weekly basis, I'm going to be
like, OK, we're good.
America's fine.
But we have such a low tolerance
that we need to go out of our
way to be like, Oh my God, look
at all the gun deaths.
I mean, if you take away, if you
take away suicides, which are
personal choice issues, you're
left with.
Hey Google, if you take away
suicides, how many gun deaths
are there a year?
Sorry, I don't understand.
Let me see.
Take your time.
If you take away all gun
suicides, how many gun deaths
are there a year?
Sure thing.
In a nutshell, if we look at the
most recent numbers, around
2023, there were roughly 46,700
gun related deaths in the US,
and about 58% of those were
suicides.
That means once you remove
suicides from the inflation, the
number of annual gun deaths
drops significantly.
Still, the exact 2024 figures
are fully in yet, so it's a
pretty big chunk of the total
and it really changes the
picture.
Do the math for me.
Absolutely.
Let's do a bit of number
crunching alchemy.
So if we take roughly 46,700
total gun deaths and remember
about 58% are suicides, that's
around 27,000 or so suicides.
Subtract that from the total and
you've got about 19,700 non
suicide gun deaths per year,
give or take.
So that's the tally when you
take suicides out of the
equation.
All right.
So reduce that into the whole
concept of rate, because you can
go ahead and hide a bunch of
really awful numbers if you say
what the rate is per our 400
million people in America, what
is the rate of gun deaths in
America?
Absolutely.
Let's put on our number
Whisperer hat.
If we're talking rates, you're
right.
Looking at raw totals alone can
hide the real stale.
So let's take that roughly
19,700 non suicide gun deaths
per year and divide by about 400
million people in the US.
That gives you a rate of roughly
0.049% per year, or about 4.9
non suicide gun deaths per
100,000 people annually.
In other words, when you put it
in terms of population rate,
it's a few per 100,000 people
each year, which definitely
paints a more nuanced picture
than the big raw numbers alone.
All right, out of that 19,700
non suicide gun deaths per year,
how many were murder?
In 2024, out of roughly 19,700
non suicide gun deaths, about
79% were homicides.
That works out to around 13,100
homicides for the year, which
comes down to about 35 gun
related murders each day on
average.
And what is the rate?
All right, let's turn that into
a nice Kitty rate.
If we take those roughly 13,100
homicides and spread them over a
population of about 400 million,
you end up with the rate of
about 3.3 gun homicides per
100,000 people per year.
So that's the ballpark.
A few homicides per 100,000
folks annually.
All right, let's go even further
and say how many of those were
legal defensive gun related
deaths versus illegal gun deaths
with regards to killing.
So putting it all together, in
2024 the US saw about 19,700 non
suicide gun deaths overall.
Out of those roughly 79% were
homicides.
So about 15,600 gun related
murders.
In contrast, legally justified
defensive gun uses or DG use are
a much smaller slice of the pie.
Estimates on defensive uses vary
a lot, but they're significantly
fewer than the number of illegal
homicides.
Basically the vast majority of
those non suicide gun deaths are
indeed homicides rather than
legally justify shootings.
Fascinating.
Thank you.
Oh, by the way, you're on my
season 10 episode 2 podcast of
the Chris Abraham Show being AI
guest a guest expert.
Oh, it's fantastic.
Well, I'm honored to be a guest
star on Season 10, episode 2 of
The Chris Abraham Show.
Sounds like a great season
already.
I'll do my best to keep it
interesting and maybe sprinkle
in a little verbal confetti
along the way.
Thanks for having me on the
show.
You're welcome, mahalo and
Aloha.
Mahalo and Aloha right back at
you.
It's always a pleasure to ride
the airwaves of The Chris
Abraham Show.
If you need more verbal surf
sessions, just say the word.
You are such a pantry cornball,
it drives me nuts.
Fair enough, I did promise you a
triple helping of snark and wit.
So let me doubt on the cornball
factor and keep it more real.
Thanks for the reminder.
I'll keep the fluff to a minimum
and the edge at Max.
Anyway, neither here nor there,
but considering the 400 million
firearms in America, it's still
too many deaths, right?
12,700 a year, that's still too
many.
But that's a hell of a lot less
than hey, will you let, will you
help me?
Are you there?
Hey, will you help me compare
apples to oranges a little bit?
Absolutely.
I'm here and ready to do a
little apples to oranges
juggling act.
Let's mix those metaphors and
see what kind of fruit salad we
end up with.
So let's say, let's say there's
19,700 murders, gun murders a
year.
And then we compare that like
after you strip down all the
suicides and all the negligent
discharges and all the mistakes
and all the etcetera, let's say
it's 19,700 and 2024.
Compare that to other similar
things such as vehicular deaths
or drownings or accidents or
bicycle accidents or other kinds
of things that apples and
oranges kind of jerks like me
like to make comparisons against
because I think everybody
forgets.
Oh, and stabbings and blunt
force trauma.
And compare the 19,007, the
12,700, is it 12,700?
Compare that to the other other
kinds of homicides with other
kinds of weapons, any other
weapons like blunt force trauma
or or stabbing or whatever.
And then, of course, compare it
to just general the number of
Americans who just die on their
own every year, because I think
people forget that humans are
mortal.
So I want you to make all kinds
of absurd comparisons to things
like, oh, and one thing that
everybody forgets is that guns
were designed to kill things,
whereas probably all those other
things were not designed to kill
things.
So the killing guns killing
things is actually a design
intention.
All right, let's dive into the
fruit bowl of comparisons and
toss a few oranges at those
apples.
So if we're looking at about
19,700 gun homicides a year as
our baseline apple, let's
compare that to some other
oranges that people often
forget.
For instance, there are monthly
40,000 or so total vehicle
related deaths per year in the
US.
That's about twice the number of
gun homicides.
And nobody designed your car
specifically to kill.
Some might argue they're pretty
good at it by accident.
Now let's toss in drowning
deaths.
Those are around 4000 a year.
Bicycle accidents causing death
are a few 100 per year, and
other accidental deaths like
foals or unintentional
poisonings.
Add 10s of thousands more and
yes, humans are in deep mortal
and we lose a couple million.
People, no, no, you you missed
out on the other types of
homicides such as stabbings,
etcetera that aren't gun deaths.
I got it.
You want the whole homicide
fruit basket and not just the
gun variety.
Let's peel that orange.
So if we have about 19,700 gun
homicides, let's compare that to
the number of homicides by other
means like stabbings, blunt
force trauma, and so on.
In a typical year you might see
around 1500 to 1800 homicides by
stabbing and a few 100 by blunt
objects like bats or hammers.
All the non firearm homicides
together add up to a few 1000
per year.
Definitely smaller than the
firearm slice of the pie, but
still part of the overall
picture.
And you're absolutely right,
guns have a unique design
purpose that makes them a
different category from say a
kitchen eye for a car.
So while we can compare numbers
all day, it's always a bit of an
apples to oranges scenario at
heart.
Anyway, neither here nor there,
so I guess I've really gotten
off the reservation.
But yeah, I think that the more
dangerous the domestic
environment gets through
protests and anti fascist
activity, the better it will be
for the domestic War on Terror
and the deportation industrial
complex.
Because the more it's kind of
like Chinese fingers cuffs.
Hey Gulu, what are Chinese
finger cuffs according?
To.
Wikipedia.
A Chinese finger trap is a gag
toy used to play a practical.
Joke on unsuspecting children
and adults.
The finger trap is a simple
puzzle that traps the victims
fingers in both ends of a small
cylinder woven from bamboo.
The initial reaction of the
victim is often to pull their
fingers outward, but this only
tightens the trap.
Perfect analogy.
Perfect.
Thank you.
You're very welcome.
Anyway, so it's a finger trap.
It is.
The more the the more the the
the anarchists take to the
street, the more protests that
have any teeth to them, the
better for the taking off of
gloves.
The domestic War on Terror and
the deportation industrial
complex can be.
It is a provocation environment.
All of you know that.
I believe that that the West
provoked Russia into war, and
that makes me really popular for
being invited to Thanksgiving
and dinner parties.
But yeah, I think that Donald
Trump and his administration is
doing everything that they can
to provoke more violence so that
they can respond with more
retaliation.
It is a trap, and we'll see.
It hasn't sprung yet, but yeah,
11 U-Haul van driven onto 1
military base resulted in every
single every single guard at the
gate ripping that van with with
with M4 automatic fire.
So like there is a in in, in
Infinity of tripwires and I am
amazed.
It proves that God exists and
loves us in so far that every
day isn't, you know, 10 to 20
Kent states.
So on that note, Merry Christmas
and Happy New Year, and I assume
that you've completely and
utterly regretted listening to
season 10, episode 2 of The
Chris Abraham Show.
If you want, you can subscribe
or you can unsubscribe.
You can find me at an Infinity
of places.
I am Chris Abraham on Instagram.
I'm Chris Abraham on Twitter.
I'm Chris Abraham on oh, here's
some news that I don't think
I've reported yet.
PS After four years of my Chris
Abraham YouTube channel being
basically wiped off the mat map
wiped off the map, I appealed.
Now that Donald Trump is in
office and the tech Bros are
becoming emboldened, I appealed
to YouTube and they restored my
they restored my channel.
So youtube.com slash at Chris
Abraham is completely restored.
And it goes all the way back, I
think, to a video I uploaded in
2005 or 2007, something like
that.
I'm really glad that they didn't
purge all of my videos.
Like they didn't even give
someone else my handle.
It was like just restored as if
by magic.
I lost three years.
But I mean, I'm amazed.
So kudos to YouTube.
The next episode, I think I'm
actually going to talk about
Nick Fuentes.
So if you're interested in that
conversation, that should be a
doozy.
But for now, you can also reach
me at Mastodon.
I have three accounts.
I have I'm Sir Chris at no
authority dot social, I'm Chris
A at Macedon dot social and I'm
Chris at Abraham dot SU.
So Abraham dot SU is my TLD
Soviet domain that I was able to
get, which I think is awesome,
but apparently the dot SUTLD is
going bye bye in 20-30.
So I was going to kill my
Abraham dot SU Mastodon
instance, but it's only four
years left and I might as well
just hold on to it for nostalgia
and not just make it a throwaway
like alias to my website, but
just make it something special.
So on that note, you can reach
me at You can reach me via
e-mail, Chris at Abraham dot SU
works.
It's on my business card 'cause
I think it's so cool.
You can also reach me.
I think Christopher Abraham is
my TikTok and I am my
micro.blogischrisa.org.
My sub stack is Chris
abraham.substack.com.
I'd love to see you there.
My threads is Chris Abraham.
My blue sky is I don't know how
I did this, but my blue sky is
Abraham dot SU.
That's my handle there.
I thought I was like getting the
domain but in fact I gave up
Chris Abraham there and got
Abraham dot SU instead.
I'm on discord but I don't know
how to share that.
Oh well, you know I'm on mesh
mesh tastic.
I'm Abra if you can reach me in
sexy S Arlington Heights,
Virginia, DM me via via mesh
tastic and maybe another episode
I will talk about.
I will talk about Pluribus as
well, 'cause the last episode
dropped a week ago or something.
Anyway, please like, subscribe,
unsubscribe, review and comment.
And be sure to block me
everywhere because after saying
things like this, I'm sure I'm
going to be everybody's favorite
Uncle Chris.
This has been season 10, episode
2 of the Chris Abraham Show.
Thank you for listening this far
through.
And after the outro, there's
going to be an Infinity of
notebook LM slop for you to
enjoy.
Bye bye.
Thank you for listening to The
Chris Abraham Show.
Make sure you subscribe so you
don't miss any future episodes.
Until next time.
OK, let's just jump right in.
We've got a really compelling
set of sources in front of us
today, and they force you to
look at a few things together
that you might not normally
connect, right?
We're talking American military
policy, our domestic economic
structure, and immigration
enforcement.
The sources we've looked at draw
a straight line through all
three.
A very Direct Line.
So our mission for this deep
dive is to, well, take a deep
breath and wade into a single,
highly provocative thesis that
this material puts forward.
And it is provocative.
The idea is that the shift from
a global War on Terror, the GWAT
as we all know it, to a domestic
equivalent, what the sources are
calling the DWAT or domestic War
on Terror.
It's not just a change in
strategy, not at all.
The argument here is that it's
being framed and and actually
executed as the massive modern
job creation project.
And here's the kicker.
It has a disturbing functional
resemblance to the New Deal.
It's a shocking comparison.
And what's fascinating just
looking at our prep is the sheer
breadth of the materials we're
synthesizing for you.
I mean, it ranges from really
speculative geopolitical
commentary to, you know, deep
historical critiques and then
down to these very granular
economic structures.
And even hard data on violence
statistics.
Exactly.
So our task is pretty complex.
We had to synthesize the sources
central claim, which is that
domestic conflict specifically
through what they call the
deportation industrial complex
or DIC, is becoming the ultimate
economic engine for the country.
An economic engine.
Yeah, a necessary 1.
So we'll need to look at the
three big pillars of this
argument.
First, the geopolitical reason
for this pivot.
Second, the massive economic and
logistical machine of the DIC
itself.
And third, these authoritarian
comparisons the source uses to
frame how the public is, you
know, brought on board.
And we absolutely have to hit
that core argument right away
because it really dictates
everything else that follows it
does.
It's the assertion that the
deportation industrial complex
and this new domestic War on
Terror are functionally and
financially the new American
make work projects.
They're designed specifically to
absorb all this military and
defense spending that, well,
can't say, easily be deployed
abroad anymore.
It completely reframes
enforcement, not as a policy,
but as essential infrastructure.
Let's start right there with the
economic theory that the source
says underpins this whole pivot
because it's it's fundamentally
cynical.
It is, the source claims that
foreign intervention, and
they're blunt about it.
Invading other countries isn't
just a policy of the United
States, they say.
It's the primary reason for
America's sustained economic
success.
The source literally calls it
the best business plan ever.
The best business plan?
So according to this analysis,
why is foreign conflict
considered so profitable?
Well, the material lays out this
very unsentimental view of war,
right?
It's all about industrial
consumption and capital
expenditure.
The source gives 2 main reasons.
The 1st is you could call it
Inventory Management I.
Guess inventory management.
Yeah, it identifies military
hardware, especially weapons and
bombs, as the best expensive
consumables that the defense
industry has.
Consumables.
That's the word to use for it
like paper towels, not billion
dollar fighter jets.
Exactly.
But in the defense context that
the source describes, the
consumption is absolutely
guaranteed.
Weapons are intentionally
destroyed.
You know when you fire a missile
or drop a bomb, or they're
unintentionally destroyed When
the tank or the ship they're
attached to gets blown up by the
enemy?
So either way, it's gone.
It's gone.
This deliberate, high value
destruction creates A
continuous, absolutely endless
demand for replacement.
It's a perfect feedback loop.
It ensures manufacturing lines
keep running.
Defense contractors have
guaranteed orders, and the
trillion dollar budget is, you
know, perpetually justified.
It's consumption that's designed
to require more consumption.
That's the model.
That sets a really dark tone for
this whole discussion.
So continuous destruction equals
continuous economic health.
What about the second rationale
you mentioned?
It deals with real estate and
infrastructure, which that seems
a little counterintuitive when
you're talking about war.
It is, but it's the second part
of the engine development and
construction, or more
accurately, the destruction,
that's necessary for rapid
reconstruction.
The source argues that foreign
conflict avoids all the usual
red tape you'd get if you were
reclaiming land or doing a
massive retirement project at
home.
So no zoning boards?
Exactly.
When infrastructure or, you
know, entire city blocks are
destroyed in a conflict zone,
the rebuilding effort that
follows, often funded by
international aid or US
contractors, is a huge, rapid
economic driver.
And crucially, that effort
bypasses all the complex
domestic hurdles like
environmental reviews or, you
know, local political fights
that slow down big projects
here.
So conflict literally and
administratively clears the
ground for rapid capital
injection and of course
reconstruction profits.
And the material is pretty stark
about what the actual cost of
this is.
Oh, it is.
The source suggests that the
only real cost is lives, which
it implies is just an acceptable
externalized cost for a global
hegemon when you weigh it
against the continuous economic
benefits.
But this model, this whole
engine of constant foreign
capital consumption, is now
supposedly running into some
problems.
Right, some obstructions.
According to the sources, how is
it being obstructed?
The source points to two
specific political constraints.
1st, it's the stated position of
a prominent political figure,
Donald Trump, who was allegedly
extremely obsessed with not
invading other countries.
So a non interventionist stance.
Exactly.
And if you take that stance
seriously, it represents a major
threat to the established
military industrial economic
engine, which absolutely relies
on continuous foreign engagement
to move capital.
OK, so a shift in political will
from the top.
What's the second obstruction?
The second is a constraint from
legal visibility and activism.
The source claims that
international bodies,
specifically the International
Criminal Court, the ICC, are
being so obstructed by activists
the traditional large scale
military adventures are just
becoming more complicated.
Riskier.
Maybe riskier or at least
politically unpalatable for the
US in the short term, the source
suggests that the visibility of
potential war crimes or just the
difficulty of operating without
intense public scrutiny, is
forcing A strategic rethink.
And this is where the material
pivots so dramatically because
the source posits this, this
terrifying, almost transactional
big invasion plan as a possible
reaction to domestic opposition
against this internal pivot
we're talking.
About Yeah, this part is pretty
wild.
The analysis claims that the
more activists protest
deportation missions and border
enforcement, the more likely it
is that the US will pivot back
to massive resource heavy
foreign interventions.
It even names countries.
It does.
Venezuela, Nigeria, Syria,
Sudan, Chad, Yemen.
The material frames this as a
kind of coercive political
economics.
It's like if the domestic
solution, the DIC is too
difficult to implement because
of protests, then the
established system will just
revert to its preferred model,
massive foreign wars to keep the
economy going.
It's presented as a strategic
lever, like accept the internal
enforcement or we'll be forced
to go back to global war.
That's viewing foreign policy
purely through the lens of
economic necessity and not
geopolitics.
But since these truly massive
foreign invasions, you know,
against powers like Europe,
Russia, China, are not feasible
yet, the immediate solution,
according to the source, is to
invade America internally.
And that sets the stage.
This is the entire context for
the domestic war and the massive
internal spending that comes
with.
It that's the critical link, the
trillion dollar defense budget,
it has to be spent somewhere.
The personnel, the soldiers and
defenders of democracy, used in
that imperialistic sense, they
have to be engaged.
So if you can't deploy them to
fight and rebuild abroad.
You deploy them internally to
fight and control threats, or at
least perceive threats at home.
Which brings us to the sources
most shocking comparison, the
deportation industrial complex
as the bizarro mirror New Deal.
That analogy is central.
We really need to unpack what
the source means by that.
It describes the DIC as an FDR
work style make work New Deal,
but you know, twisted into this
authoritarian inverted project.
So the original New Deal in the
30s was this massive federal
spending program, you know, the
Civilian Conservation Corps, the
Public Works Administration,
designed to give people jobs and
build physical infrastructure
during the Great Depression.
Roads, dams, parks, public
buildings.
So functionally, they both exist
to absorb massive amounts of
federal money and employ huge
numbers of people.
How does the source see the DIC
accomplishing that same goal?
Well, the modern version, this
DIC and what it serves the exact
same economic function.
It engages massive resources,
employs countless people across
federal, state and private
contracts, but its purpose is
inverted.
Inverted how?
Instead of building public goods
for the unemployed, it builds
detention infrastructure for a
targeted population.
It substitutes traditional
infrastructure like roads and
bridges for enforcement
infrastructure, prisons, vans,
logistics systems.
It's still capital expenditure,
but it's aimed at internal
control, not civic uplift.
That contrast the function being
the same but the moral purpose
being the opposite.
That's the heart of the
argument, and the source implies
that this massive domestic
spending actually has a lot of
support from Americans.
Correct.
The source says public buy in is
absolutely essential, just like
it was for the original New
Deal.
The material claims this is
widely supported because a
significant chunk of Americans
believe that, you know,
somewhere between 10 and 40
million undocumented people,
often framed as mostly military
age men, have flooded the
country.
And that narrative is amplified
by another fear.
Right, the belief that hundreds
of terror cells are embedded and
just waiting to execute a
massive coordinated attack or
even a government takeover.
So the perception of an
existential internal threat, the
terror cells, the scale of the
undocumented population, that's
what grants the political
permission for the enormous
spending needed to run this
so-called Make Work project.
Exactly.
It's a self justifying cycle of
fear and spending.
The source argues that if you
can convince the public that the
threat level demands spending on
par with a trillion dollar
defense budget, then the
morality of what you're spending
it on becomes secondary to the
perceived need for action.
So the New Deal comparison isn't
just about the economics of job
creation.
No, it's also about the
political framework, creating a
program that the public accepts
as absolutely necessary for
national security and stability.
That thesis that the DIC is
basically an inverted New Deal,
It demands that we look at the
legit logistics of it, because
this is where the make work part
really translates into contracts
and jobs.
The source frames the DIC as
this huge nationwide
infrastructure project.
An extension, and really a
dramatic expansion of the
existing prison system.
So we need to establish a scale
here first.
The source gives some data on
current prison spending right to
show what's already being spent
on detention.
It does.
Total U.S. government expenses
on public prisons and jails is
cited at around $80.7 billion a
year.
Private prisons add another
what, 3.9 billion?
But the deportation industrial
complex, according to this
analysis, doesn't just tap into
that stream.
It has a completely new layer
that is exponentially larger
just given the sheer scope of
the target population they're
talking about.
And the size of this new layer
is described in almost
unbelievable terms.
The source talks about the
infinite resources required for
mass deportation, right.
If the political goal is
actually to deport 5 million, 20
million or God forbid, 50
million people, the source says
the inner structure required is
just immense.
Nationwide, it would require
infinite resources.
In that term, infinite
Resources, it's used
specifically to emphasize the
scale of employment, not just
the cost of materials.
The source argues that this task
requires mobilizing the entire
logistical and legal apparatus
of the federal government, plus
endless private sector
contracts.
It's the sheer complexity of
moving housing and processing
that many people that guarantees
the continuous spending.
Let's get into that resource
list.
This is the operational
blueprint for the Make Work
project.
What does the source claim is
needed to keep this economic
engine humming?
OK, so you start with physical
containment.
If you're targeting 50 million
people, the source estimates
you'd need something like
500,000 detainment centers, half
a million, or at least a rapid
expansion into temporary
facilities.
On that scale, this means
massive immediate construction
contracts building, securing and
maintaining half a million
sites, even if they're
temporary.
That's the physical
infrastructure.
What about the people needed to
run it all?
Well, that's the real job
creation part.
The source is you'd need an
infinite number of judges,
lawyers and federal agents,
including FBI just to handle the
process accessing and the legal
challenges.
So it's a boom for the legal and
law enforcement sectors.
A massive 1.
You're creating entire new
career tracks, new training
programs, expanding federal
agencies exponentially.
On top of that, you'd need state
police and National Guard units
to help with logistics and
security, pulling them onto the
federal payroll for these
missions.
And what about the material
goods, the consumables for this
internal conflict?
That goes right back to the
economic engine we talked about
at the start.
The source predicts A continuous
need to buy an infinite number
of ammunition, an infinite
number of sidearms and battle
rifles for all these newly
expanded agencies.
And the vehicles to move people.
Oh yeah, the whole logistics
chain, the continuous buying and
maintaining of specialty
vehicles, black Suburbans,
transfer vans, buses, and then,
crucially, chartering infinite
commercial airlines or setting
up these lucrative private air
contracts to actually move
millions of people across
continents.
The scale of that logistics
chain by itself is just
staggering, But the source says
the recurring money really flows
from the soft infrastructure,
the daily support services.
Absolutely.
The support services create this
vast network of secondary and
tertiary jobs.
I mean think about feeding,
watering, lodging and providing
medical care for potentially 10s
of millions of people who are
constantly cycling through
detention.
So.
Massive federal contract.
For catering companies, for
pharmaceutical suppliers,
medical staffing agencies, it
goes on and on.
And the source gets even more
granular than that, right, To
show how deep the spending goes
into the economy.
Precisely.
We're talking about the
infrastructure.
Just to run the centers you need
guards, security systems,
building contractors, HVAC,
maintenance and then the basic
supply.
The source mentions catering,
bedding, shampoo and
conditioning.
Shampoo and conditioning.
Yeah, these mundane items, when
you're buying them in quantities
to supply half a million
facilities housing millions of
people, that represents
multibillion dollar recurring
federal contracts for everyday
goods.
So the argument is that the DIC
replicates the economic impact
of small prison towns where the
whole local economy depends on
the prison, but it does it on a
nationwide scale.
That's the mechanism.
The DIC model creates a massive
number of primary jobs agents,
guards, judges and secondary
jobs suppliers, contractors,
builders, and they are all
reliant on the sustained
guaranteed funding of the
federal deportation budget.
It absorbs unemployment and
defense spending at the same
time.
Which is why the source calls it
the new Make work program.
The infrastructure being created
is well, it's a detention state.
Right, but the source also
claims that the system is
designed to avoid ever reaching
that maximum scale through the
intentional mechanics of
enforcement, specifically
through the deliberate
militarization and the delivery
of trauma.
Trauma delivery.
That's a chilling phrase.
It is, the source says.
This is the resource saving
aspect of the plan.
It highlights the intentional
use of intimidation and fear
mongering tactics designed to
cut down on the number of people
you have to physically detain
and process long term.
So what does that look like in
practice?
It involves highly militarized
appearances, wearing masks,
going in hot and aggressive
tactical gear, using things like
flash bangs, door kicking, even
rappelling from helicopters for
these highly visible traumatic
raids.
Why the theatrics?
Why this hyper aggressive
deployment?
How does the source define this
intentionally traumatic
delivery?
It's.
Defined as a force multiplier,
If you're an enforcement agency
trying to affect millions of
people with, you know, finite
resources, you need to maximize
the psychological impact of
every single encounter.
And the goal?
The goal, according to the
source, is to traumatize illegal
residents so thoroughly that
they consider America an
untenable environment and choose
to self deport.
Even if it's just temporary.
Right, it's about delivering
fear and disruption.
So trauma becomes a logistical
tool.
It's exactly it's psychological
warfare to reduce the need for
physical infrastructure.
If 10 people self deport out of
fear, for every one person you
physically detain and process,
you dramatically decrease the
number of judges and supermax
beds and long term contracts you
need.
The speed and intensity of the
operation saves resources while
still achieving the political
goal.
This focus on massive, federally
funded enforcement brings us to
a really challenging part of the
sources the authoritarian
comparisons, starting with the
New Deal itself.
For most Americans, the New Deal
is this untouchable sacred cow.
Right.
It's seen as the gold standard
of effective and active
socialism that saved the
country.
But the source presents a
completely different, very
critical view a.
Heterodox view for sure.
It claims the New Deal was in
many ways a nationwide
gentrification project, a
massive federally backed eminent
domain project disguised as
modernization.
So while it provided relief and
built infrastructure, the source
is saying the process involved
the federal government seizing
private land for huge projects.
That's the critique, the idea
that by concentrating so much
power and bypassing local
ownership, the New Deal had this
inherent, maybe subtle,
authoritarian streak despite its
benevolent goals.
And the source draws a really
startling historical parallel to
emphasize this point about scale
and public buy in.
It does.
It compares the works program to
Hitler Lite and Hitlerian.
Whoa.
OK, we need to be very, very
clear here.
The source isn't equating the
New Deals ideology with Nazism.
No, absolutely not.
We have to stress this is the
sources extreme claim.
The comparison focuses purely on
the shared historical context of
massive, rapid state
mobilization in response to a
national crisis.
A crisis which required citizens
to accept enormous government
power and sweeping federal
intervention.
Exactly.
And the source then asks
rhetorically about the history
that's often omitted.
The people against which the New
Deal was weaponized, the
communities whose land or
livelihoods were just steep,
enrolled by these nationally
mandated projects.
And if we connect that back to
the deportation industrial
complex today, the source is
arguing the DIC achieves a
similar public buy in by
targeting A perceived threat,
undocumented immigrants and
terror cells.
Right, thereby justifying
authoritarian methods under the
guise of national necessity and
economic stabilization.
It's the core claim of
inversion.
The New Deal built
infrastructure for the citizens.
The DIC builds infrastructure to
contain and expel A targeted
population.
But both are state mandates that
require wide public acceptance
to succeed.
And Speaking of targets, the
source is very clear about who
gets labeled a criminal in this
context, which is crucial for
maximizing the stale of the make
work project.
Yeah, this is a key point.
The source notes that when
supporters of this effort,
specifically the Mangia
supporters mentioned in the
source, say criminals, they
often mean anyone who is in
breach of their legal residence.
So not just violent felons.
No, anyone who is illegal, even
if the breach is purely
administrative, like an
overstayed visa or a
documentation error.
This massively expands the
target pool, providing, you
know, endless work for the DIC.
And the militarization of these
deportations then feeds into a
counter disruption strategy
designed to handle the
inevitable backlash from
activists and protesters.
Those who protest the missions
get them tangled up in
misdemeanors, felonies, or just
completely disrupt their lives
with costly legal fees and
constant harassment.
So it's less about conviction
and more about just
immobilization.
That's it, and the source uses
this striking analogy for that
strategy.
Judo or Aikido to describe how
they handle defiance.
Yeah, it's a powerful analogy
in.
Judo or Aikido, you use your
opponent.
'S own energy and momentum
against them.
The source suggests the DIC is
designed to use the protesters
energy of defiance to destroy
their own lives.
Their resistance becomes the
fuel for their own legal
entanglement and demoralization.
It's a planned counter
disruption strategy where the
opposition's activism.
Becomes self-destructive.
Then there's the.
Specific strategy for sanctuary
jurisdictions, which are the.
Biggest political obstacle to
this The source calls sanctuary
cities ideal fishing grounds,
right?
The material analyzes the
practical limits of that
sanctuary status.
While it acknowledges these
protections are important social
constructs for local safety, the
core assertion is that mayor's
just can't counteract a
presidential decree when it
comes to the force doctrine.
So when federal agencies like
ICE are operating.
Under a mandate, local political
optics might get damaged, but
federal force is legally.
And logistically, superior
sanctuary cities just offer a
high density of the target
population.
That's the fishing grounds
metaphor with very limited local
capacity to actually stop
federal operations, that
distinction between local
political resistance and federal
kinetic force.
Is key.
OK, So what about the actual big
baddies?
The literal members of gangs,
terrorist organizations, the
cartels?
Who are the political
justification for all of this?
The source makes a crucial
practical distinction here.
If an individual is.
Genuinely a high value member of
a cartel or a terrorist group,
they will not be deported.
Why not?
Because deportation is an
administrative action.
You just remove someone.
These individuals need a
different kind of processing, a
judicial punitive process.
Exactly.
They will instead be put.
Into supermax prisons.
And this is where the source
introduces the idea of
outsourcing the problem.
These supermax prisons, the
source suggests, will be located
in foreign prisons all over the
world.
A penal colony, the modern
version of it.
Out of sight, out of mind.
The high risk detainees aren't
deported.
They're perpetually contained.
Just not on American soil.
And that concept, exporting the
physical consequence of
detention, is a perfect.
Segue into the sources analysis
of modern globalism.
It is the idea of locating
supermax prisons abroad connects
directly.
To the concept.
Of NIMBY not in my backyard.
The source defines this global
outsourcing of consequence as
NIMBY writ large, and it uses
California as the paradigm, the
ultimate NIMB state.
It claims the state has
meticulously driven out its
industrial base, oil refineries,
corporate headquarters like in
out, Oracle, Tesla because the
economic and environmental
impact of industrial production
is just too.
Messy for the pristine
progressive image the state
wants to maintain, right?
But the consumption continues.
Which is where that famous
Dorian Gray painting?
Analogy comes in.
This is a powerful metaphor for
global embryism.
The.
Source claims that California's
pollution and industrial work
have been outsourced.
Primarily to China.
China incurs the carbon
footprint, operates the
factories, deals with The Dirty
labor, the sin, and then puts
the finished goods on a
container and ships them to
California for consumption.
Without the carbon footprint.
So California remains beautiful
and green like the unblemished.
Portrait of Dorian Gray while
the moral and environmental cost
of its consumption is borne by
the.
Painting itself, which is hidden
away in this base China or other
developing nations.
So the argument is that modern
globalism is just NIMBY writ.
Large not just not in your
backyard, but not even on your
continent.
That's the definition the source
uses.
It's the outsourcing of
undesirable.
Social, economic and
environmental costs to maintain
domestic comfort and this
provides the perfect context for
understanding the shift from
GWAT to DWAT right if the global
War on Terror was about
outsourcing.
Violence and death to foreign
lands, making conflict happen
somewhere else, then the
domestic War on Terror.
The DWAT is the logical
reversal.
You bring the force doctrine
home because the economic engine
demands it.
Precisely.
So what does the source claim is
the transition and what's the
expanded target list for the
SWAT?
Well, the source says the GWAT
targeted civilians abroad often.
Labeling legitimate freedom
fighters as terrorists and using
remote force like drone warfare.
The DWAT is the domestic
application of that exact logic
and force doctrine.
But to justify that apparatus
you need a massive expanded
target list.
You do.
And the list, according to the
material, relies on expanding
the definition.
To include groups that blur the
line between criminal and
political action, narco
terrorists, cartels.
And this is crucial for the
political dimension, the formal
definition of Antifa as a
terrorist organization.
And that terrorist label is key.
It's essential because.
Applying that label allows the
US to.
Apply drought.
Style surveillance force
doctrines and indefinite
detention capabilities right
here at home, justifying the
massive internal security state
created by the DIC.
The ultimate goal, then, is to
establish the idea that the
country is.
So infiltrated that an infinite
number of 9/11 type of Paris's
have infiltrated American life,
that they're staging multiple
terrorist events or preparing
for a government takeover.
That perception is what
justifies the authoritarian
spending absolutely, the
perception of an invisible,
ubiquitous enemy operating
internally.
Is what provides the political
oxygen for the dwat.
And this strategy of internal
targeting leads directly to what
the source calls the Chinese
finger trap approach, a strategy
of intentional provocation
against activist groups.
Right, Let's talk about this.
Pressure cooker analogy The
source claims the
administration's alleged goal is
to turn America into an anti
progressive, anti antifa, anti
deportation pressure cooker.
Why would they do that?
The objective is psychological
and strategic.
It's to make people lose their
stuff and to use the sources
colorful phrase Red Dawn against
the government.
The administration is allegedly
seeking an internal flashpoint,
a violent reaction.
Exactly.
The source suggests that if
lefties.
Anarchist Climate.
Activists and Free Palestine
protesters are fooled into
escalating their actions,
transitioning from protest to
actual physical violent
confrontation.
It will quickly cascade into
real world consequences,
gisticuffs, small arms conflict,
or even a return to something
like. 1970s Weather Underground
style terrorism, right?
And the Chinese finger trap
analogy perfectly describes the
mechanism.
Of this provocation so, well,
the analogy is stark.
The more anarchists and
protesters struggle and defy the
government's deployment, the
tighter the trap gets.
The resistance provides the
documented justification for
taking off of gloves and the
full heavy-handed deployment of
the DWAT and DIC.
So the source explicitly claims
the provocation is intentional,
yes.
The resistance itself is
strategically channelled and.
Used as the moral justification
for the counter response,
tightening the trap around civil
liberties and protest movements.
So the stability of this whole
make work apparatus depends on
the.
Government either fabricating or
successfully provoking genuine
violence from its domestic
opposition.
That's it.
That violence is the ultimate
justification for the trillion
dollar.
Expenditure.
If the state can document
genuine organized violence from
the opposition, the massive new
security infrastructure will be
retroactively justified in the
eyes of a public that's already
been primed to fear those
hundreds of terror cells.
This whole aggressive pivot
seems motivated by an intense
fear.
Of widespread violence.
And yet the source offers this
fascinating analysis of what
Americans actually worry about
versus the objective statistical
risk.
Yeah, this part is really
interesting.
The claim is that people don't
really care about big.
Crimes like billionaire
corruption.
Or large scale inner city
violence, but only the crimes
that personally affect their
daily lives.
Quality of life crimes.
This is a crucial political
distinction the source makes.
It argues that.
While macro level issues like
white collar crime are
objectively more damaging to the
economy, they don't drive
political demand for massive
enforcement spending.
What drives the demand for the
dwat is the perceived breakdown
of daily.
Order exactly, and the source
lists those specific immediate.
Quality of life concerns.
What are they?
Highly visible crimes?
Car break insurance, Stolen
catalytic converters.
Personal muggings.
Pickpocketing, which the source
calls the European problem,
suggesting it's something
Americans find especially
intolerable.
Carjacking.
Smash and grabs, right?
Especially if you're a store
owner.
And maybe most relevant to the.
Political mood, the visible
disorder of homelessness and
drug use, even down to just the
smell of stinky weed and the
source claims America has such a
low tolerance for danger and
this.
Kind of visible disorder that
people have to actively go out
of their way to highlight
statistical anomalies like
overall gun deaths.
The argument is that for the
average American, the baseline
level of public.
Order is so high that any
visible disruption, like a
stolen catalytic converter,
creates this intense demand for
intervention.
So the the political necessity
of the DWAT in DIC isn't really
rooted in stopping terrorism,
but in restoring the perception
of total order and safety in
daily life.
And this low tolerance for
danger makes it essential that
we actually review.
The statistical data cited in
the source about gun deaths,
which they use to frame the real
risk environment in the US.
Let's slow down and walk through
the numbers the source provides,
starting with the baseline cited
for 2023.
OK, the baseline total annual
gun related deaths cited in the
material.
Is around 46,700.
This is the big number you often
hear reported, but the source
immediately strips out a massive
component to frame the issue
differently.
It does.
It removes suicides, and it
notes that they account for a
staggering. 58% of that total,
that's approximately 27,000
deaths.
And the source categorizes these
as personal choice issues or
mental.
Health crises arguing they
should be statistically separate
from homicides when you're
talking about external threats
to public safety, right so by
stripping out suicides, the
source dramatically lowers the
baseline for.
Comparison, you're left with
approximately 19,700 non suicide
gun deaths per year.
OK, so just under 20,000 and the
source then translates this into
a.
Rate for the 400 million
estimated.
Population which comes out to
roughly 4.9 non suicide gun
deaths per 100,000 people
annually.
The first notes this paints a
more nuanced picture of external
risk than the raw totals, and if
we dig deeper into that non
suicide total, the source is
about 79.
Percent of those deaths are
homicides.
That's the next critical
breakdown.
So 79% of that 19,007. 100 gives
you approximately 15,600 gun
related murders.
This is the vast majority of non
suicide deaths, which translates
to a rate of about 3.3 gun
homicides per 100,000.
People per year.
The source also notes that legal
defense of gun uses are a much
smaller slice of the pie.
Right.
And the material emphasizes that
while every homicide is a
tragedy.
Putting this number in context
is essential when you're
evaluating the public's
acceptance of a massive domestic
War on Terror.
The fear level that's being
promoted needs to be way out of
proportion to the actual
statistical reality for the
strategy to work.
Which brings us to the famous
apples to oranges juggling act.
That the source material
performs comparing these gun
homicide totals to other, less
politically charged causes of
death, this comparison
highlights a real societal
paradox, the source notes.
That there are roughly 43,000
vehicular deaths per year in the
US.
That's about twice the number of
gun homicides exactly.
Yet vehicular deaths are.
Generally tolerated as an
unavoidable risk of.
Modern life while gun violence
is treated as this existential
threat that demands a massive
military response.
And the comparison goes, it
does.
Drowning deaths are around 4000
a year.
Other accidental deaths.
Like falls or unintentional
poisonings are in the 10s of
thousands and then you have non
firearm homicide stabbings which
are between 1500 and 1800 and
blunt objects only a few 100.
So guns are clearly the most
common murder weapon by far.
The gun homicide total is
significantly larger.
Than all other forms of homicide
combined.
But the source notes that guns
were well designed to kill
things, making that comparison
inherently skewed in terms of
efficacy.
This whole data deep dive sets
the stage for the sources final
observation.
Which is maybe the most
surprising part of this whole
thing, The paradox of American
restraint.
Yeah, despite the pressure
cooker environment and the
political narrative of.
Internal chaos.
The source expresses genuine
shock and notes the benevolence
and restraint of what it calls
the highly militarized and
trained superior force, which
includes IC and the National
Guard.
The source finds it remarkable
that every protest, every
deployment, doesn't just
escalate.
Into a total catastrophe.
Precisely.
They say they're super impressed
that every day is not a Kent
State.
A mass shooting incident
involving the National Guard and
protesters.
The material points to the high
training and superior armament
of law enforcement, whose ratio
is 2.3 officers per 1000
residents.
And yet they exhibit this
incredible operational restraint
even when provoked, the source
jokingly says.
This daily lack of violence
proves.
That God exists and loves us.
It does, and this restraint is
mirrored by the American
populace itself.
Who possess an unprecedented
amount of private firepower.
That's the other side of the
paradox.
The source notes the existence
of over 400.
Million mostly unused firearms.
In private hands, it suggests
the civilian population also
demonstrates a very strong
trigger discipline, that old
principle of don't fire until
you see the whites of their
eyes.
So despite the polarization and
the vast arsenal, the system
remains.
Surprisingly stable, right?
And the numbers back up the
scale of that arsenal, the
source estimates.
Americans by between 8 and 15
billion rounds of ammo every
year.
The average possession is 80 to
150 rounds per gun owner.
Wow.
So the existence of this vast
unused domestic firepower
coupled with the restraint of
militarized government forces
highlights this core, almost
miraculous tension in the
American system.
But the source as one final
warning that big disruptive
events like January 6th or
outright false flag events are
often fermented by intelligence
agencies or what they call color
revolution agenda outfits rather
than organic citizen action.
It suggests external
manipulation is needed to truly
break that internal restraint.
So we've taken a comprehensive
look at the sources, complex and
frankly, extremely.
Provocative claim that American
economic success is
fundamentally tied to conflict
and that current geopolitical
constraints are forcing this
pivot inward right, and this
pivot embodied by the
deportation industrial complex.
And the domestic War on Terror
is framed as this modern
authoritarian take on the FBR
New Deal, a strategic mechanism
designed to absorb the defense
budget and create internal
employment through perpetual
enforcement and detention.
We've detailed how this economic
necessity, according to the
source, relies on.
Intentional trauma as a force
multiplier, how concepts like
NMBY are used globally to
outsource moral and
environmental costs, and how
statistical data can be
manipulated to frame the
perception of safety.
Or danger, which then justifies
these immense expenditures.
And we covered that terrifying
strategy of intentional
revocation.
The Chinese finger trap, where
the defiance of activists
against the DIC is allegedly
used to justify escalating the
dwat, turning that resistance
energy back against itself.
The source ultimately closes on
this observation that the simple
lack.
Of daily violent escalation.
The fact that there aren't
multiple Kent states or bombings
every single day is this almost
miraculous indicator of a deep
seated restraint from both the
superior militarized force and
the heavily armed citizenry.
Right.
So considering the sources
ultimate claim the violence is
being.
Intentionally provoked to
justify retaliation and the
necessary expansion of this
deportation industrial complex.
What is the extreme trigger
discipline and surprising
operational restraint of both
sides?
Tell you about the current
stability or maybe the inherent
fragility of the American
system, especially if the source
is correct.
The defiance only serves to
tighten this intentional Chinese
finger trap.
Our discussion today focuses on
the conceptual framework.
Of what's being called the
Deportation Industrial complex,
or DIC.
Now, this term describes the
massive nationwide
infrastructure designed to
conduct and manage the mass
removal of undocumented
individuals.
The critical question that
really comes out of our source
material.
Is this?
What is the primary function of
this colossal apparatus?
Is it, at its core a modern
internal works program aimed at
economic stability, Something
similar in, let's say,
structural necessity and scale
to the role the FDR New Deal
played?
And I'll be presenting the
alternative perspective here.
I maintain that.
While the spending footprint is,
of course, enormous, the DIIC is
fundamentally defined by its
methods.
It's explicit reliance on
trauma, on intimidation, and
frankly on punitive
militarization.
This makes it an instrument of
social control and conflict
generation.
It's it's structurally distinct
from any historical works
project.
I would argue the methodology
completely supersedes the
economics, and I'm going to
argue that the economic
mechanism is in fact.
Primary The DIC is the internal
spending vehicle that is
required to maintain the
economy.
It fills a role that, you know,
has traditionally been occupied
by large scale military
engagement abroad position
statements.
So my core thesis is based on
the structural logic of the
modern defense state,
historically foreign military
adventurism, which the source
material a bit provocatively
calls the best business plan
ever because it relies on
expensive, intentionally
consumed weapons.
That has been the engine for
trillions in federal spending.
When a political administration
is constrained, for whatever
reason in overseas
interventions, that massive
budget still exists.
It has to be directed internally
to prevent a domestic economic
collapse.
The DIC therefore becomes the
necessary replacement.
You're framing this purely as an
economic imperative, then A.
Straightforward spending funnel.
Precisely.
It's the bizarro mirror New Deal
a make.
War or make work program that's
been turned inward.
I mean, if we seriously consider
the scale required for the mass
deportation of what, 20 to 50
million people, the required
infrastructure is effectively
infinite.
You're talking about building
and maintaining detainment
centers, mass hiring of judges,
lawyers, and federal agents,
procuring specialized vehicles
like black Suburbans and
transfer vans, and then
contracting commercial airlines.
And this scale requires massive
tertiary support, food services,
medical care, HVAC, catering.
This investment is massive
enough to act as a recession
proofing economic engine,
engaging the same volume of
personnel that would be required
for a military engagement
abroad.
OK, well, while I can concede
the spending footprint is vast.
I really have to challenge the
structural comparison to the New
Deal.
I come in it from a different
angle.
The DIC is, I believe,
fundamentally extinct because
it's design is not constructive
or modernizing.
It is explicitly A punitive and
psychologically damaging
security apparatus, what we're
calling the Domestic War on
Terror or DWAT.
And even if we admit the New
Deal was, you know, an
authoritarian project focused on
modernization, the DIC operates
purely on the basis of trauma
delivery.
But even that violence has an
economic cost that translates
directly into spending it.
Does but look at the operational
goal, the.
Intent is to achieve mass
removals not just through
logistics but through
psychological force.
The overreach, you know, the
flash bangs, the door kicking,
the display of heavily armed
federal agents, That's all.
What the material cause
intentionally traumatic
delivery.
The goal is to traumatize people
so thoroughly that they self
deport this focus on fear, on
expulsion.
That defines.
The system and makes a parallel
to works programs, which are
traditionally about national
reconstruction really
insufficient.
And furthermore, if the economic
argument holds, the system would
need to maximize long term
infrastructure.
But the private prison component
often cited as a key part of the
deck, it accounts for a
relatively small portion of
correctional spending compared
to public facilities.
This suggests the projected
infinite scale needed for long
term detention.
May be, you know, conceptually
rhetorical, which questions the
enduring economic equivalence.
I have to reiterate that the
structural logic still dictates.
That the economic function takes
precedence.
The system is designed to create
a New Deal style economy off of
these giant deportation programs
to ensure economic survival
during a downturn.
The punitive elements, They're
secondary.
They are merely the most
efficient way to deliver the
primary objective, which is a
funded, sustained internal
operation.
I'm sorry, but I just don't buy
that the economics supersede.
The stated operational intent.
If the explicit primary goal is
traumatic self deportation, then
your long term demand for
infrastructure, the works
component you mentioned, will
actually decrease drastically as
people leave.
This seems to prove the system
is optimized for enforcement and
violence delivery in the short
term, not long term
infrastructural employment.
The spending is concentrated on
militarized personnel and
equipment to manage conflict,
which immediately transforms a
mission into a domestic War on
Terror.
That's an interesting challenge
that operational success
undermines.
The economic structure, however,
I'd say the D Wat itself is the
works program in a modern
context.
So even if the target population
shrinks, the target list
expands.
The D Wat requires the system to
pivot, labeling other domestic
groups, protesters, political
opponents as narco terrorists or
cartels to justify the continued
massive budget for agents and
equipment.
The expenditure remains.
It's simply redirected toward
internal security mobilization
rather than just immigration
logistics.
The structure finds a new crisis
to monetize, so the core
function of the DIC isn't stable
employment.
But perpetual conflict
generation just to maintain
funding, that is a crucial
distinction from the New Deal,
which aim to create stable long
term employment through
constructive projects.
Let's let's delve into the
authoritarian nature of both
projects.
You noted that the New Deal
involved authoritarian elements,
displacement through eminent
domain, but the DIC is built on
outright deliberate provocation
to justify its own size.
I'd like to clarify the
mechanism we mentioned earlier,
the Chinese finger cuffs
analogy, right?
That analogy refers to the
system strategy of escalation.
The federal forces conduct these
highly visible, highly traumatic
enforcement actions.
Raids, arrests, neighborhood
sweeps.
This is designed to provoke a
guaranteed, often violent
response from targeted
communities or activist groups
like anarchists.
The ensuing resistance then
provides the political and legal
momentum for the superior state
force to respond with more
retaliation and thus use the
energy of the protest to further
destroy the lives of those
people.
That mechanism of self
generating conflict is when I
think.
Fundamentally.
Separates the two historical
projects.
While the New Deal used
authoritarian control and
displacement for the purpose of
national modernization, building
dams, roads, power grids, the
DIC uses authoritarian control
for destabilization and the
creation of a self feeding
conflict loop.
So the New Deals violence was
the cost of construction.
The DI CS violence is the
primary operational input.
The system is designed to
consume human conflict in fear,
not simply to pave roads.
I'm just not convinced that the
difference in methodology
negates.
The.
Shared structural outcome.
The violence you're describing,
while calculated, is
structurally analogous to the
necessary overhead for any large
scale governmental project
involving internal military
deployment.
The source material often notes
that in foreign adventurism,
lives are the only acceptable
cost for the hegemon.
If you turn that spending
inward, the resulting domestic
violence and social disruption,
they become the politically
acceptable overhead for
achieving the larger defining
goal, the creation of a massive
funded internal structure that
stabilizes the flow of military
industrial spending
domestically.
Let me introduce another
structural element that I think
reinforces the equivalence the
not in my backyard or NIMBY
framework.
The DIC also facilitates the
exportation of punitive measures
which mirrors globalism strategy
of you know, outsourcing
undesirable effects like
California sending its pollution
offshore.
The most genuinely high level
security threats, terrorists and
hardened gang members.
They won't be deported to
unstable nations, instead
they'll be placed in supermax
prisons abroad.
It's what the material calls the
penal colony idea.
The foreign supermax concept is.
I agree, undoubtedly.
Pure NIMBY.
It's the outsourcing of
undesirable citizens.
Exactly.
And this aligns both the New
Deal and the DIC.
The New Deal used eminent domain
for local dislocation, moving
people out of the way of
progress.
The DIC simply pushes the truly
undesirable further away,
outside the continental borders.
Yet it's still funded by the
Internal Works Program.
It's a strategy of displacement
and spatial control common to
both.
OK, but while I can see that the
NIMBY mechanism applies.
Perfectly to the foreign penal
colony aspect if fails when
applied to the core works
program thesis For the
deportation industrial complex
to function as the necessary
internal economic engine, the
enforcement, the hiring, and the
trauma delivery must take place
domestically.
It requires the invasion of
America by its own federal
forces.
This domestic mobilization
inherently creates instability,
conflict, and fear, a situation
that's contrary to the
stabilization goals usually
associated with massive
government works, projects
designed to restore public
faith, as the New Deal was
intended to do.
But that instability is
precisely the currency that
justifies the continuous.
Funding of.
The mobilization and that leads
us directly back to the
justification for the domestic
War on Terror itself, and we
have to question the genuine
scale of the domestic threat
used.
To justify this mechanism, the
political narrative focuses so
heavily on quality of life
crimes, catalytic converters,
stolen smash and grab, the fear
of mugging.
Does this genuine, statistically
verifiable threat level really
warrant a works program of this
immense scale and level of
militarization?
The statistical threat level is.
It's secondary to the.
Political utility of the
perception of threat.
The political buy in is what
funds the works program.
We really have to use the source
materials quantitative framing
of societal instability,
specifically gun violence, to
understand this gap between
reality and funding
justification.
All right, let's use the numbers
to clarify this political
distortion, OK?
So total gun deaths in the US
are approximately. 46,700
annually.
Crucially, 58% of those are
suicides.
If we remove those personal
choice issues, we're left with
around 19,700 non suicide gun
deaths and specifically gun
homicides, the number most
often.
Weaponized for security
narratives, that stands at about
15,600.
So that yields a rate of
approximately 3.3 homicides per
100,000 people annually.
The quantitative comparison is
staggering.
This homicide.
Rate is significantly lower
than, say vehicular deaths,
which hover around 43,000
annually if we proposed a
trillion dollar internal
mobilization to eliminate
traffic deaths, it would be
deemed absurd.
But the perception of pervasive
insecurity fueled by political
rhetoric and media focus on
those 15,600 homicides.
It enables the government to
state that the domestic
environment is dangerous enough
to warrant the massive,
expensive, militarized internal
mobilization the DWAT, which
concurrently fulfills the
economic need for a large scale
internal spending project.
The perception of pervasive
insecurity the constant sense
that the.
Home front is a war zone is the
necessary ingredient for
politically sustaining the
economic spending apparatus.
I can accept that perception
drives the currency, but I'd
argue that because the
statistical reality is so
disproportionate to the scale of
the W at response, it
underscores that the system's
primary goal is not economic
stabilization, but the political
utility of maintaining A
perpetual state of internal
emergency in control.
My position remains rooted in
structural economics.
The.
Demands of maintaining economic
hegemony require a massive
internal spending mechanism.
The deportation industrial
complex fulfills this need by
leveraging A perceived internal
crisis, migration and terror to
mobilize personnel and
resources.
And while the methodology is,
yes, highly punitive and fear
inducing, the fundamental
structural role, the creation of
a vast funded apparatus that
keeps the military industrial
complex alive domestically is
analogous to the stabilizing
function of the New Deals Works
programs during the Great
Depression.
And I maintain the analogy fails
due to critical differences in.
Methodology and intent.
The New Deal was at its core
infrastructural and modernizing.
It aimed to build and stabilize
the nation physically.
The DIC is structurally defined
by the strategy of traumatic
delivery and deliberate
provocation, that self feeding
conflict loop.
Its intent is to militarize
internal policing and dismantle
communities through fear, making
it fundamentally an instrument
of social control and calculated
conflict rather than national
reconstruction.
The New Deal built dams, the DIC
builds walls of fear.
Yet both create a massive
government funded apparatus that
sustains.
A.
Significant portion of the
workforce when other avenues of
spending are constrained.
I think our discussion confirms
the materials intellectual
complexity.
Large scale government action is
rarely a simple choice.
It often carries both economic
imperatives and course of
functions simultaneously.
The central question remains,
which function defines the
structure?
We must continue to analyze how
the modern state prioritizes, so
let's jump right in.
Our first point is really.
About focus, the sheer breath of
these high stakes, provocative
concepts, it ultimately dilutes
the singular compelling power of
the central thesis, which is
that deportation industrial
complex, the DIC.
As an economic stimulus, exactly
the material is so ambitious it.
Brings in the domestic War on
Terror, or DWAT, which is great,
but then it jumps to all these
other complex analogies, right?
And it's not that the ideas are
bad.
They're profound.
But they're treated, you know,
associatively.
They don't feel like they're
structurally supporting the main
economic argument.
I see that you get that sudden
shift to the Dorian Gray thing
with.
California outsourcing its
carbon footprint, right?
The NIMBY analogy.
And then from there we go into
this.
Really.
Deep.
Statistical breakdown of gun
mortality rates and I can see
that the authors point
illustrating denial or.
A low cultural risk tolerance,
but you lose momentum.
You do.
I think there's a real risk
there.
If your core argument is about
building this new national
spending machine, a works
program needing, and I'm quoting
infinite detainment centers, you
have to keep that financial
engine right up front, yes.
But by spending all this time
on, say, the California analogy,
you get sidetracked.
Suddenly the listener is
debating environmental policy or
gun statistics Exactly.
And they're not wrestling with
the terrifying financial.
Necessity of the DIC.
Which is the whole point.
That is the whole point.
So the suggestion is really.
About editorial focus.
Re center the entire thing
around the economic case for the
DIC and dwat.
Make everything else serve that
one idea, every single tangent.
Has to justify why it's there
it.
Has to strengthen that central
financial framework or, you
know, it has to go.
And to make that really
actionable, you have to be
ruthless.
That California section, is it
truly essential?
If not, I'd.
Say cut it just.
For velocity.
But if you keep it, you have to
reframe it completely.
How so?
Don't let it be about Nimb yism
in general.
Frame it.
As the perfect.
Illustration of how the US
manages negative externalities
and then make the leap.
The leap being that the DIC
turns the undocumented.
Population itself into that
externality precisely.
Now it's not a tangent anymore,
it's integrated proof.
It's.
Part of the core logic and you
can do the same thing with the
statistics.
That whole section breaking down
gun.
Deaths, you know, taking it from
the big number down to the
homicide rate.
So long aside right now, a very
long aside.
It needs to be transformed.
Make it short.
Sharp and impactful.
It should prove one thing and
one thing only.
The low cultural tolerance for
risk.
Yes, that's what the DWAT.
Needs to get public support.
Prove that.
And then immediately get back to
the money, the economics of
militarizing that response.
The numbers have to serve the
budget justification, not start
a whole.
Separate debate.
I think if that happens, the
thesis will.
Just have so much more clarity
and.
Power right now it feels like 3
separate brilliant essays
competing we just need them all
marching in formation yeah OK so
if the first point is.
About tightening the focus.
The second is about, well, it's
about giving that core
historical analogy the steal it
deserves, the New Deal
comparison, the crucial
comparison, it.
Needs deeper historical texture.
To be more than just a
rhetorical provocation, it has
to actually support the claim
that the New Deal was an eminent
domain project in the guise of
modernization, which is a huge
claim.
A huge claim, the material
calls.
It an FDR work style make.
Work.
Program, but in a bizarro
mirror.
It even uses the term Hitler
Lite.
OK, so that's a staggering thing
to.
Say about the new Deal, it is,
and I wonder if we've really
considered the immense.
I mean the immense.
Burden of proof that comes with
a claim like that, especially
when the author themselves says
the New Deal is in America's
sacred.
Time exactly to call it
extremely authoritarian and.
Despotic.
And the script uses those exact
words that requires just
knockout counterintuitive
evidence, or else it just sounds
like noise, right?
It's an explosive comparison.
But if it fails, it risks.
Derailing the entire argument
into just being contrarian for
its own sake.
And that's the weakness right
now.
The analysis just states the
parallels works.
Program national pride it
doesn't give the specifics of
who the New Deal was quote
weaponized against appoint the
author flag themselves as
needing work so the
gentrification claim it.
Just hangs there.
It feels unsubstantiated.
So the suggestion has to be to
strengthen it with just one or
two concrete evidence.
Based examples Yes, examples of
the New Deal's authoritarian
side that directly mirror the.
Human costs of the DIC.
We need to see that dark
reflection in the bizarro
mirror.
OK, so for concrete examples we
could.
Pinpoint a specific program like
the CCC, the Civilian
Conservation Corps, or the PWA
right and you find documented
systematic exclusionary
practices.
Or you find where federal
eminent domain was used for land
acquisition that led directly to
displacement, and then you
explicitly contrast that with
the DI CS use of land for.
An infinite number of detainment
centers.
You show the historical
mechanism of control side by
side.
And the.
Money link is absolutely vital
here.
You have to define.
The economic purpose of the DIC
as an extension of the private
prison system, which already
costs billions, then show how
the New Deal also monetized a
national crisis.
So you're linking the cost of
trauma and displacement in the
DIC to the?
Unacknowledged socioeconomic
cost of displacement and.
Control back in the New Deal If
you can show how the New Deal
controlled populations for
national gain, the analogy is
suddenly robust, defensible.
It moves beyond rhetoric and
into.
Verifiable history.
Which is what this audience will
demand.
They'll want that rigor without
it, that.
Hitler like comparison is just a
distraction.
But with it, it grounds the
sheer scale of the claim it
validates.
The insight?
OK, let's move on.
Our third and final critique.
This one is about.
How the mechanism of trauma
delivery connects back to the
economics right.
The analysis of intentional
trauma and conflict needs.
To be.
Explicitly tied back to the core
economic viability of the
deportation industrial complex,
OK.
And the material is incredibly
effective at detailing the
aggression.
It talks about flash bang
grenades, door kicking, the JSOC
drag attire and it frames them
as intentional tools to
traumatize people into self
deporting.
Exactly.
And it also suggests very
astutely that.
Protests are being provoked.
It uses that great Chinese
finger cuffs analogy to say that
resistance is being used to
justify more aggression and
trigger the D Watt.
That all makes sense.
You see the action, the trauma,
and the desired.
Psychological outcome?
Self deportation.
But here's the question I have.
If the core thesis is that the
DIC is a massive multibillion
dollar economic works program
meant to employ millions,
wouldn't self deportation
actually undermine that?
How do you mean?
Well, why build infinite centers
if people are leaving on?
Their own before.
You can process them.
It seems like a paradox that the
material introduces but doesn't
quite resolve.
Ah, and that's the beautiful,
terrifying twist of it.
The weakness here is that the
discussion of provocation,
waiting for the left to Red Dawn
against their own government, it
feels focused on conflict and it
feels separate from the
economics.
It feels political, not
financial, right.
We need to, clearly.
Spell out why this expensive
trauma.
Delivery is a necessary part of
the Bizarro Works program, so
the suggestion is to frame the
trauma and provocation as direct
evidence.
Of the DI CS superior
operational efficiency making it
financially irresistible exactly
you articulate how.
Self deportation reduces the
need for.
All those centers, judges,
charter flights, you'd need to
deport 40 million people.
The trauma becomes a cost saving
measure, a force.
Multiplier for the economic
project it proves.
Its own terrible rationality
that framing changes everything.
Trauma isn't just malice.
It's a budget optimization tool.
It's terrifying.
So for a concrete example, the.
Author could explicitly link the
success.
Of traumatizing people who are
here illegally to the reduced
operational load on the DIAC
infrastructure.
Fewer apprehensions, fewer beds,
less catering, less.
Medical care reduced reliance on
chartering an infinite number of
commercial airlines.
The initial investment in trauma
pays dividends by cutting long
term bureaucratic overhead.
And that's where the Chinese
finger cuffs analogy becomes a
financial.
Mechanism the provocation
guarantees the conflict you need
to justify the spending.
More protests mean more
justification for militarized
spending for federal.
Jobs the works program the
violence guarantees the
necessity of the.
DeWalt framework and its
trillion.
Dollar budget while the trauma
it creates optimizes the
deportation rate it's a self
feeding financial loop it's
brilliant and horrifying and we.
Can refine one last piece, the
part about sanctuary.
Cities being the best fishing
grounds, we should detail how
the federal power to override
local decrees makes that local
defiance a tool.
It concentrates your enforcement
resources so you focus your high
cost, high visibility actions in
specific.
Areas maximizing efficiency and
maximizing the public
consumption of the DIAC in
action.
You turn political defiance into
a centralized budget
justification, turning defiance
into a core argument for federal
employment.
That's a.
Powerful adjustment.
It links the political reality
straight to the economic model.
The material is so strong, it's
original and deeply provocative.
But tightening that focus and
really substantiating the New
Deal analogy, that's what will
make it robust enough to stand
up to serious scrutiny.
I genuinely believe this piece
has explosive potential.
We just want.
To help strengthen the internal
structure to support the weight
of these incredibly significant
claims, the path forward is
really clear.
So, to quickly summarize the
three big suggestions, first
focus.
The scope let the DIC economic
thesis dominate and use those
fascinating tangents only as
tight supporting evidence.
Second, deep in that historical
comparison to the New Deal.
Add specific critical evidence
to really validate the bizarro
mirror analogy.
And third, make sure that the
analysis of trauma and
provocation.
Is explicitly tied back to the
core economic and operational
efficiency of the whole
deportation industrial complex.
It's impacted promises.
We invite you to submit the
revised material.
Back in for another look on the.
Deportation industrial complex
and the domestic War on Terror
so.
This analysis looks at large
scale security operations like
mass deportations in a really
different way.
It suggests they're actually
massive domestic jobs programs,
kind of like a bizarre
militarized mirror image of the
New Deal.
OK, so first up is what's called
the deportation industrial
complex.
The whole idea is that it's
designed to create this huge
internal economic stimulus.
I mean, think about it.
To deport millions of people,
you'd need endless detention
centers.
You'd have to charter airlines
and hire a massive number of
federal agents, judges and
lawyers.
It's a way to spend the military
budget, but right here at home.
Second, this whole thing expands
into what's called the domestic
War on Terror.
The focus shifts from overseas
threats to people right here.
So you see domestic political
groups like anti fascist or
socialist getting labeled as
terrorist organizations.
The strategies described as a
kind of jujitsu move.
You basically provoke people to
protest the deportations and
then use that very protest
against them to justify a much
wider crackdown.
It's a trap.
And finally there are the
tactics.
They call it intentional
traumatic delivery.
We're talking door kicking,
raids, repelling from
helicopters, flashbangs.
It's all designed to be a
massive show of force.
The whole point is to make life
so psychologically unbearable
the people here illegally will
just self deport.
So in the end, this strategy
uses both immigration and
protest as a dual excuse to
militarize the economy and
radically expand government
power.